each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available thank you for coming I see a
lot of a lot of friendly faces in the
crowd um and hopefully the online
presence is good as well I'm Justin
Styles um I'm a part of OSG security and
we're sponsoring along with research
this talk that Josh is going to be
giving us um there is a signup sheet uh
somewhere around the room yeah raise
your hand if you got it so if you happen
to make all six in person you will get a
special prize so um online doesn't count
sorry everybody but uh we're that's kind
of one of the fun things that we're
doing to get you to show up um we hope
it's an interactive conversation so Josh
is ready to take questions during the
talk or you can say them until after um
uh but make sure you sign up the sheet
on the sheet uh if you're if you're here
if you're present uh it won't be
something you won't win a vacation to
Disneyland or anything but it won't be
some random chachki it'll be worth
hopefully worth coming for if you if you
started today so um okay so Josh in my
eyes really needs no introduction if if
you want to if you want to know
cryptography or have questions on
cryptography he's kind of the guy you
guys can read his bio you know he's well
qualified but um don't let him uh don't
let him slip by if you've got any random
crypto questions during his talk I think
he's up for the challenge so let's give
a round of applause to Josh Bena
please okay thank you very much Justin I
presume I can be heard good um those of
you who are online and didn't know about
the prize you can I guess still make it
here by the end of the talk and and get
your name on the list um so uh yeah just
to you know make it clear what's going
on um we've got six six sessions planned
this first one is going to be pretty
much a broad overview touching on a lot
of things at a very high level and then
the remaining five will dive into um
more detail on various things um and
there going to be some flexibility I've
got you know some things in mind that I
want to be talking about but if you have
things that directions you want to take
things let me know and and I hope we'll
be able to
accommodate so anyway uh to start things
off um a lot of people like to talk
about internet security that's kind of
why many of us are here um and uh it's
worth remembering that um the internet
was not designed at all with security in
mind it was designed basically for a
small number of mutually trusting and
trustworthy entities to to exchange um
whatever they wanted to um and pretty
much you know sending anything on the
Internet is like you know sending a
postcard through the mail in a case
where you don't really trust the Post
Office um so it's a difficult
environment to work in um but we can we
can manage some things so what does a
typical internet transaction look like
so assume we've got you know you out
there browsing the web and maybe some
Merchant you want to buy something from
let let's say uh you want to get a book
from Amazon so you might may have an
exchange let me look at this oh there's
the information oh I like that well
people who looked at that seem to have
Lo looked at these books also so okay
you look at those books and eventually
maybe you get to a point where you hit
well okay good you've convinced me I
want to buy
something so Amazon is very happy I say
great please send us your credit card
number well okay here's my credit card
number now remember that thing about
postcards and whatnot this is not a very
good State of Affairs so we want to find
a way to do better than this
ideally everything that whole
conversation is protected so that people
can't see my browsing history and and my
Amazon um browsing history um just in
that little environment but at the very
least we'd like to encrypt or some way
protect the credit card numbers so that
only the merchant sees them even that's
a problem I'll talk about that later but
you know let let's try to get that as
our first goal and this is going to take
us a while this going to take us most of
the next 30 minutes or so so to begin
with it's worth mentioning kof's
principle this dates back about 130
years and says that if you're building a
security system that the um this the
system itself the security of the system
itself shouldn't depend on everything
being hidden you shouldn't use security
through obscurity you should be able to
make everything you're doing public
except some very small bit piece which
is the key okay that's the goal and it's
interesting at this time locksmiths
adopted this
wholeheartedly um and that's an industry
that has now flipped the other way and
they like oh you shouldn't be able to
understand how work you know you knowing
how locks work makes you a special
person who we have to to keep track of
so that that's an industry that's based
now very largely on security through
obscurity not knowing the tricks and how
to pick a lock for instance um there are
other industries that have gone you know
hard in that U direction of trying to
hide things but interestingly some
Industries have embraced this coming out
in the open not just cryptography but
for instance the gaming
industry Las Vegas you can go to
conferences and workshops where they'll
talk about all their vulnerabilities
completely openly what what tricks have
been used at the blackjack tables in the
last 12 months or whatnot and they'll
talk about things and and they've
decided that Sunshine's a good thing and
I think Sunshine's a good thing I think
this principle is is worth following but
you know it does mean you have to you
know be very careful with your keys um
so when it talk about keys let me talk
about what I mean by a key first of all
I'm not talking about a
pin right this is just a little tiny
nothing I'm not really talking about a
password either this is you know
something small something pretty
guessable most of the time what I mean
when I talk about a key is a big random
at least
128bit string okay
so the reason that this is important um
is that um pins and passwords have a
place but they only have a place where
offline attacks are not possible so um
you think of what happens if you try to
enter a password too many times you get
locked out very
quickly if I had a way of checking
through a password space without being
on online without interacting
then passwords pins wouldn't work at
all for cryptography though if we're
going to encrypt something you can check
offline whether what what possible key
will decrypt it and when you have an
offline attack then anything like a pin
or password is is terrible so everything
may be subject to an offline attack and
it's something we we need to consider um
and an attacker just as a rough estimate
might be able to search through as many
as 2 to the 64 values that's a a good
you know indication of the size of the
space that an attacker may be able to
search through um now think about what
that is that would be you know all
numerical pins of fewer than 20 digits
there are very few people who I've seen
enter 20 digigit Bank
pins passwords fewer than 14 lowercase
letters most of our password words
aren't quite up to that well we could we
could add a few characters to the
alphabet how about Alpha numerics you
know still fewer than 12 characters or
printable password still anything fewer
than 10 characters is in some sense
searchable now these things still work
for the the online only application of
entering a password to get access to
something and you get locked out but if
you try to use this in a cryptographic
manner as a key you're going to have
have
problems so don't even think about using
any user chosen password as as
encryption key please um nor anything
that's been derived deterministically
that's just as bad um basically given
some Cipher text an attacker can just do
some sort of a an exhaustive search a
guided search through this space of you
maybe up to two to 64 things and crack
your user
chosen um password for anything um so
basically there's no such thing as a
user chosen key think of this a key as
something that's really just a big
random
value um something that doesn't apply
that much anymore but I I decided to
keep this in um is uh dictionary attacks
because you do hear people talk about
these against you know a space of uh of
password say and the idea is is
basically
if it it can often be the case that you
try
one password and encrypt this common
password 1 2 3 4 5 AB bcde whatever and
then you can sort of scan through
everybody and try it to see you know
where this encryption matches something
because you saw a way that was encrypted
so there's a little trick that's often
used here of make sure everything is
encrypted differently and use some sort
of assault some sort of an initial value
it can be public that value but make
sure it's a different value for each
encryption in some way and we'll be
using that a lot more later and in the
next session okay so let's get get into
the meat of things into the essence and
start talking about what you might think
of as encryption and encryption starts
out as symmetric encryption basically
symmetric encryption is there's a key
I've shared a key with somebody else I
use the key to encrypt you use the key
to decrypt that is traditional
encryption as it existed for literally
Millennia um Caesar ciphers in fact can
be thought of as that so that that goes
back quite a way um so how do we do
this um well when we talk about
symmetric ciphers there are usually two
major classifications two broad groups
of of symmetric ciphers we can talk
about stream ciphers and block ciphers
and I'll spend a few minutes talking
about each and showing you how they they
work and we'll spend more time looking
at these in a future session so stream
ciphers are a few examples but really
rc4 this one is like everything um this
is you know like
99.9% of of what you see a A51 is is
used in cell phones so that that has
come up a little bit more L but rc4 used
to be like 99% of all encrypted traffic
anywhere in the world was
rc4
um and what you do with any stream
Cipher is basically you build a pseudo
random generator if you've ever seen a
pseudo random generator um you know
thought about these these things are
very very important for many
applications but all a stream Cipher is
is just a puden generator and all you do
is you take the stream of output bits
from the Pudo random generator and
exclusive or it with plain text to form
Cipher text so here's pretty much what
it looks like you take your plain text
you take your seed you put it into your
pseud Rand number generator and you
create a stream of um key bits and you
just exclusive or every bit and you get
a bit of Cipher text okay
now how do you decrypt you do exactly
the same thing you can even use exactly
the same function the cipher text goes
in the top gets exor when you exor with
the same key bits twice you get back to
where you started you got the plain text
back it's very simple very easy and so
so much so that I will show you one
common um example so I can talk about
alleged rc4 there's an interesting
history here rc4 is a uh is a trade
secret of the RSA
Corporation it has presumably been
leaked there has been
leaked um implementations and leaked
descriptions of what this looks like but
technically still if you use rc4 you
have to pay the RSA Corporation but as a
trade secret this thing called alleged
rc4 has has been discovered it seems to
on all inputs and all outputs that
anybody's tried do exactly the same
thing but we will talk about alleged rc4
here so it's quite simple you take a
bite array of 255 256 bytes and you
stick in all possible values in
order you also take another array of
exactly the same size and you replicate
your key as many times as necessary to
fill this array so it's completely
flexible you can use a 128bit key is is
commonly the case you could use a
shorter key you could use a longer key
just you know repeat the key fill this
array with that key repeat it over and
over and then just for this the setup
you go through this little tiny Loop 256
times and what you're doing is just
shifting this array around you will
still have when this is over um all 256
possible bytes in that array they'll
just be in a different order so what I
do is take um what's in position I here
and what's in position I here and add
them with J which started at zero and
compute a value and then just swap two
elements in this
array I just go through a bunch of times
and do a swap and get it all scrambled
up and this key caused the the swapping
to be done and once this initialization
is complete this 256 steps of
initialization then you can start
streaming out byes and the way you do
this is I started at zero you just keep
incrementing
I you keep incrementing J not by one but
by the value in the I
position and you do another swap each
time so you just keep on swapping those
values in this this
array and you compute a new index which
is the two values that you swap
and you output whatever is in that
position this is the entire pseudo
random number generator known as rc4 you
can put it on a t-shirt you can put it
in two slides you can put it in any way
um but it's still
alleged um it is extremely fast it's
extremely nice got a lot of good
properties it was discovered years after
it started being used there's a little
bit of a bias in the early bites of the
output that has been used to break some
things so the curent recommendations is
just sort of throw away the first
thousand or so bytes and just start a
little bit later um okay
so um stream ciphers are great they are
typically very very fast you could see
this thing just screams right you just
do a few steps and you get another bite
and just keep on going just you know 10
Cycles or less per bite um they're very
simple um encryption and decryption can
be identical
literally but there are some problems
and I'll hit the first one right here o
what happened
there it wasn't on my machine well you
can probably guess what that operator is
supposed to
be I don't know why that but but anyway
um if you ever use the same keystream
ever ever you have a problem here's
plain text one here's plain text two
Cipher text one Cipher text
2 if you exclusive were these two Cipher
texts what happened to that key it's
gone it's that key exord with itself you
just get these two plain text exord
together and from two plain text exord
together you can usually tease those
apart now you have the two plain texts
and you can derive the key that was used
and attack anything
else this happens surprisingly often
even amongst people who know it should
happen a few years ago I was working
with a team in office that will not be
named um and using a stream Cipher and
saying yes yes we know about all the
pitfalls we're very careful we never use
the same keystream what we do to make
sure of it is we derive the key stream
based on the file name with a whole path
okay think about this for a minute so I
pointed out well that's great for
separate files but what if you change a
file and I watch 12 Jaws around a table
simultaneously
drop and yeah okay it's a mistake but
basically stream ciphers are fragile
it's really easy to mess them up here's
another way in which they can be messed
up take a look
at basic stream Cipher how we designed
it it's bit by bit every single bit
encrypts to a single
bit there's no interaction across the
bits at all now I hear people joke
sometimes that it's terrible because
anytime there's a zero here it means
that bit went
unencrypted
okay okay
good um but there's another problem when
you're doing it bit by bit it's very
easy for an adversary to alter the
cipher text in a way that'll have very
specific known impact on the plain text
right so you may have very well
structured text maybe here is some sort
of a bank transfer notice you please
transfer $2 and you know exactly what
the form of this is and here it comes
it's
encrypted and I know that the second
bite in this this value is going to have
the amount so I can just take the cipher
text and just flip one little
bit and suddenly the bank transfer is an
encrypted version of
this okay that also leads to undesirable
results well maybe desirable for for uh
Bob oh no for Alice in this case um but
you can see it can cause some problems
so these are the two biggest problems
with stream ciphers the reason that that
fragility exists um so much uh with them
is is lack of Integrity checking to make
sure that this hasn't been done and key
reuse which just happens even to people
who think they're being careful to avoid
it so Microsoft policy requirements part
of the sdl don't use stream ciphers it's
just they're so easy to mess up don't
use them they're nice they have lots of
good properties and if you really really
have a good reason you come to the
crypto board and plead your case and
we'll make sure you're doing it okay
because we do use them in places where
they are reasonable to use but but you
know as a rule avoid them okay so the
alternative is block
ciphers so a block Cipher basically
looks something like you take a key you
take some data and you churn for a while
and outcome Cipher text
okay so let's take a look at what this
this might look like so there are bunch
of ways of building these things but um
I'm going to show you a really clever
way of building block ciphers that works
very well lots of block ciphers have
been done this way it was invented a
little over 50 years ago by a guy named
horse Fel and the basic idea is you want
to make something that's a really ugly
function that really just takes bits and
scrambles them all up and it's really
hard to figure out what's going on
that's what encryption is in some sense
right but it has to be
reversible reversibility is kind of hard
but if you want to encrypt you've got to
be able to
decrypt right so how do you make this
really really ugly and messy and
difficult but also make it reversible
well here's this really clever trick you
take your input up here and you break it
up into two halves the left half and the
right half and now the right half goes
through the ugliest function you can
imagine doesn't have to be
reversible what you do with it is take
that exclusive or with the left half
comes through and that becomes the right
half and the the old right half just
goes through unchanged here now the nice
thing about this is even though you've
gone through an unre reversible function
here you can reverse this you can get
from the output back to the input by
just going up and doing the same thing
because you've still preserve the input
into here you still got it so you can
reproduce it and do the exor and get
back to where you started okay that
works pretty well except well wait a
minute we left this half
unchanged okay sure but we can do it
again so coming from here now we will do
another
now both half halves have been messed up
and actually you can do both of these
things um essentially in parallel right
because you can see uh this is coming
down uh through here well you have to
wait a little bit but you you can you
can compress the effort but now both
halves have been done and things go
through you know much more easily and
you've you've now done some encryption
well this is good it's not really good
enough usually when you do these things
you keep on churning so one thing you do
put in the key here whatever key you had
the same key doesn't have to be used in
both of these functions that can mix it
up a little bit but also you iterate so
typically one of these feisal ciphers
are iterated for at least 10 Rounds 16
rounds often more you use different sub
keys for each round and with this even
if your ugly function in the middle is
very weak you can get a very strong
Cipher by just iterating enough I would
never recommend that you roll your own
Cipher if you had to don't do it but if
you had to if you take you know some
really lame little quote ugly function
here and iterate it a 100 times through
a fol network like this you'll probably
have a pretty good Cipher it'll be slow
the trick is making it so that you don't
have to iterate it for 100 rounds that
you can reduce the number of rounds and
make it fast and and efficient and still
very strong but if you iterate it for
100 rounds you'll probably get something
that's very good
okay so um I'll just take a moment to
show you an old Cipher um that uses this
very common in the old days not so much
anymore but the data encryption standard
was the the first first widely used
public block Cipher um and the main
reason the main problem is besides being
a little slow is that 56-bit key and
remember we talked about being able to
search through a 2 to the 64 um size
space well this is smaller than that you
can do exhaustive search on on Dez um
but just to get a sense for for what can
be done and how a real Cipher can be
built um also the 64-bit plane text by
the way is a little short we prefer
larger block sizes now um but f a
feistel cipher is done here 16 rounds
let's take a look inside one of these
rounds for Dez really all that's going
on is one of these Feist still rounds
and the only thing you have to describe
is the the ugly function in the middle
and in the case of Dez it looks pretty
much like this I'm oversimplifying a bit
but you take 32 bits in because it was
64 bits the right half is now 32 bits
you take a piece of the key 32 bits
there exer them together take this break
it into eight 4bit blocks you have a
substitution table for each block that
says if you see these four bits you
substitute those four bits and then you
do a
permutation and then you have you have
16 rounds like this now the actual Dez
is a little bit more complicated but not
a lot lot what's done is this 32 bits is
expanded to 48 bits by every block
taking it a neighboring bit off of the
neighboring block and just absorbing it
and then these substitution tables go
from all six bit values to four bit
values and the the subkey for each round
is 48 of the 56 bits just taken in some
you know some different subset of the 56
bits each time that's all of Dez that's
a full symmetric encryption function a
full block Cipher okay so let's get back
to where we started we know how to
encrypt now great we can go back and
solve this problem right we get down to
the point where you want to buy
something you get the question of what's
your credit card number and you say well
here it is I can encrypt my credit card
number because I know how to encrypt
right I've got a key I can
encrypt except what likely happens is I
want to make a
purchase and Amazon might say okay well
encrypt your credit card number with our
shared key because this is how we're
doing this right and if this is the
first time you've gone there say well
what what's that shared key again
um and we could have an infrastructure
which says Okay first time you go to
Amazon you say I want to set up an
account and Via um snail mail 3 days
later Here Comes you know a uh an
envelope with a key in it and you type
this 128bit key into your browser and
now you can buy your
book well okay um if we had no
Alternatives I guess this would be the
best business model we had but hopefully
we can do
better and to do better we need to fall
on asymmetric
encryption asymmetric encryption deals
with a case of a user and a merchant
which have no prior relationship
um and allows someone to encrypt a
message without knowledge of the
decryption key so somebody in the back
of the room right now who I've not met I
could give you instructions and say okay
I want to send you a secret message I
tell you what to do do this this and
this tell me what what you got you know
pick some random numbers do this the
following things tell me what the answer
you got is I will use that answer to
encrypt my message to you and only you
will understand it that's what we can do
with asymmetric encryption and I'm going
to show you how again we'll talk about
it in more depth later but most of
asymmetric
cryptography whether it's RSA or Diffy
Helman or elliptic curve um cryptography
uses this equation in some form when we
do elliptic curves we usually write it
differently but I prefer writing it this
way even for elliptic curves the like
making the the group operation
multiplication and it still looks this
way
basically this is the equation in some
form or another that we we need to work
with and solve so let's let's look at
this equation a little bit more when the
unknown is over here you're just
Computing this modular exponentiation
and it turns out it can be computed
efficiently and I'll spend a few minutes
on that but let's look at some other
cases when this is the unknown this is
known as the discret log problem if we
sort of eliminated the mod n for a while
then you're just Computing the logarithm
of Z to the base
y right and we can do that if there's no
mod here that's easy right there are
lots of ways of doing it but you could
always do it by just sort of a binary
search an interpolation you get closer
and closer what the modn does here is it
makes things chaotic because taking
things
mod I
really realize let just make sure
everybody in the room knows mod n is
just take the remainder when divided by
n right so it's basically the just
dropping off everything but the low
order bits or low order portion of
anything so think about what's happening
there we're just keeping the low end so
think about like you have a timer that's
running really quickly and you see the
low order stuff going wild and the high
order stuff is slowly incrementing but
the low order stuff is kind of chaotic
and if we we're just taking that we're
trying to find values that cause
something to happen at the low order if
we're trying to do a binary search it's
not going to work because if we change
this just a little bit there are small
changes up at the high order stuff but
the low order stuff gets to something
completely different and binary search
just doesn't work and and other methods
just don't work okay so we've got this
thing that's believed to be hard we
don't have a proof that it's hard but it
seems to be hard
what about some other cases if Y is the
unknown this is also believed to be hard
to
solve except if you happen to know the
factorization of n it turns out root
finding which again is easy if it's not
mod n that's just finding the X root of
Z but if you know how to factor n then
it turns out you can compute Roots mod n
I'm not going to tell you how today I'll
tell you how in in a month or so if you
come back to that session um but it
turns out it's not that hard the final
one just for completeness I like to look
at this what happens if n is unknown
there's really not a lot of work there
I've heard of a couple people looked at
it but I think it's an interesting
problem you how hard is this I don't
really know but might be worth worth
investigating might be able to do
something with it okay so let's look
first at the how do we compute this why
do the X Mod n
well you might just compute y the X Mod
n by taking y to the power x and
reducing it mod
n now the problem is we like to use for
integer operations integers of at least
20 48 bits that's another crypto board
sdl requirement RSA similar things 20 48
bit minimum so if you have 20 48 bit
integers x y and N are 20 48 bits you
raise y to the X power and you get
something of about that many bits now
just for comparison that's how many
particles there are in the
universe storing this number is going to
be a
problem
right we can't come close to storing
that value so we're going to have to
find another
way fortunate Ely we can be a little bit
more
clever we can do this mod end reduction
with each
multiply so we don't ever let the value
get very big we can multiply and then
reduce and multiply and let reduce and
keep the value from ever getting big so
we can solve the storage problem that
way but to do this exponentiation by
just doing 2 to the
multiplies um we have to do a lot of
them pretty quickly that's about how
many we'd have to do every second just
to finish before The Sun Burns
Out and you know a a good processor now
can you know it's 4 gig two to the 32
computations per second right so we're
getting there right just a well okay we
want to be able to do our encryption a
little bit faster than this so here's
the
trick um think about how you learn to do
multiplication in elementary school
School multiplication is just repeated
addition nothing more to it than that
but you don't multiply 23 by 49 by
adding up 49 copies of
23 right there are tricks basically what
you could do is repeat a doubling now we
work base 10 so we don't do it by
doubling we do it Bas uh base 10
multiples of 10 it's actually a little
bit harder to learn to do it that way
think of if we were doing everything
base 2 so to compute x * Y what we can
do is just compute y oh it's not obvious
why I've highlighted a few of these yet
but it will be Y 2 y 4 y 8 y 16 Y and
sum up whichever of these we need to get
x * y so sorry I should have masked this
initially but here's the example suppose
you want to do 26
y we really should have this room tilted
in a way I see people having trouble
seeing the things low I'm sorry I don't
know there's anything I can do about
this at that this point so I'll just try
to read and make it clear suppose you
want to compute 26 y well if we write it
out in binary write 26 out in binary you
find that you need 16 y Plus 8 y+ 2 y I
don't know why I made that too green
sorry um so you instead of doing 26
additions or maybe 25 additions you're
doing four doublings and then two
additions and the doublings are
additions they're just easy
additions um so we save a lot of work
well the exactly the same thing could be
done with exponentiation suppose we want
y x well we just repeatedly Square value
and all these things are done mod n by
the way because we know we want to
reduce it mod n keep it small don't use
up the
Universe um so we do these squarings and
then we just multiply together the
things we need to get y the 26 power so
we're not doing 25 multiplies we're
doing four multiplies here four easy
multiplies here and two more multiplies
much faster so if we count it up now if
we're trying to do you multiply um 2,000
bit to do a an exponentiation of 2,000
bit values then it takes about
3,000 multiplications 3,000 ordinary
multiplications to do it basically 2,000
squarings to get all the things we need
and about a thousand side
multiplications to multiply roughly half
of these will have to be multiplied
together depending on the binary
representation of this x up here okay
make
sense questions okay good so great we
can exponentiate
quickly so now let's do our essay let's
show how we can use root finding to
solve the problems we have here of
asymmetric
encryption this is going to be RSA in
two slides and it really actually most
of it's in one slide but we can two two
slides get everything you want to know I
tell you you want to create an RSA key
take two big primes multiply them
together okay publish the product tell
everybody the product that's public now
we typically use for the x value the
exponent
65537 it's 2 to the 16th plus one it has
a very nice binary representation one a
whole bunch of zeros and a one right so
we have very few of those side
multiplies it's a nice little
convenience doesn't have to be a huge
exponent for the
encryption and would tell you to encrypt
your message y by just taking y to the
power x
mod your chosen n and since you know the
factorization of n you can solve this
discrete root problem and invert it if
you know the factorization of n you can
do this if you don't know the
factorization of then it is a secret it
is encrypted it is opaque to you that is
RSA because if you take the X power and
then the X root you get back to where
you started that's all it is in fact RSA
has another really nice property and
this is slide two of RSA signatures we
know that you can encrypt and then
decrypt the encryption and get back to
where you started but there's also this
odd little feature that you could
decrypt first and then encrypt take the
X root and then the X power you will
also get back to where you started okay
looks bizarre why would anybody want to
do that well this is something that
nobody else can do so taking the X root
of Y effectively serves as a signature
on y it's something that only I could
produce so I have signed y by producing
a value which is the X root of Y and
anybody can verify that signature by
raising it to the X power mod my n and
they get y back so that's a digital
signature great we've got encryption and
digital signatures all in one you simple
trick okay back to our confidential data
transfer our purchase from Amazon now
we're in much better shape right I want
to make a purchase really I do I'm
trying so Amazon comes along and says
okay here's my key now encrypt with that
and I send my credit card over that
channel looks good right everybody happy
no okay why not
anybody want to help I'm sorry try again
what are you sure it's their key is what
I thought I heard yep that is a a big
problem you might have an intermediary
hanging out there it's not just you and
Amazon but there may be somebody in the
middle so you start browsing through uh
the Amazon collection and the
intermediary intercepts everything and
forwards it on and gets the responses
and forwards them back and forth and
eventually you get to a point where you
want to make a
purchase and the intermediary happily
says sure I want to make a purchase and
Amazon says well here's my public key
and the intermediary says and here's my
public
key but it's different it's e tilted
crooked e uhuh okay so they send back a
crooked exponent a crooked encryption
function and you encrypt your credit
card number very dutifully to the
intermediary and now the intermediary
has your credit card
number and if the intermediary is clever
it'll then take your credit card number
and reencrypt it for Amazon so that you
get your book or blender or whatever it
is you trying to buy and you're none the
wiser and Amazon's not the wise there
but your credit card number is now in
somebody else's hands so this isn't
good
so we add a feature a digital
certificate this is basically a
statement
that somebody has signed saying what
Amazon's public key really
is if we have a certificate Authority
that can do this
signature and we believe that
certificate Authority then we know what
Amazon's real key is the problem is now
we just have bootstrapped the problem or
put it back down to okay how do we
believe the certifying Authority well
baked into our browsers are the U the
root key
of various certifying authorities so if
they're good and they do their job well
then we can trust them and everything is
good of course there are a lot of
certifying authorities in the browser
maybe some more trustworthy than others
maybe some more careful than others if
you still if you look in your browser
you can still find some um old keys that
have been um uh explicitly um disallowed
because they were issued by the
certifying authority verisign to
Microsoft because somebody called them
up and said I'm Microsoft please sign my
key please certify it and they did and
nobody at Microsoft seems to know who
that person was those keys have never
seem to have shown up but you have to be
careful so okay we've got
aert can we do this now I want to make a
purchase Amazon sends back a public key
and a certific certificate saying this
really is Amazon's
publicy and now I encrypt okay are we
good
now well we're better but yeah you're
wise you know not to trust a
cryptographer replay attack perfect
thank you I'll pay you later
um just give me your credit card and
I'll I'll be fine um so this seems to
work just fine here's a perfectly good
exchange and somebody overheard this
perfect good
exchange and then later on whoever that
eavesdropper was who overheard this goes
back to Amazon and says I want to buy
some really expensive something really
nice and Amazon says okay here's my
public key and the certificate and all I
have to do is say sure my credit card
number is is that thing whatever thing
went just over the wire last time yeah
it's the same one and Amazon dutifully
decrypts it
and um um suddenly somebody else gets
charged so we're going to add one more
component to this we're going to
add what's called a non which is a a
coined word derived from number
once um a non is just an a random value
that goes in and it changes every time
and you
send the encryption of the credit card
number together with a non and if and
the next time Amazon sends to somebody
else they'll send a different non and if
the same non doesn't come back each time
then Amazon will know wh this is wrong
disallow it okay so are we
done well we're done in the extent that
this is what's done today and I'll show
you how I'll claim it's not good enough
but let let's take a look at how this is
used today um there's a sorted history
of SSL which probably most people here
have heard heard of and TLS which
probably most people here have heard of
and PCT which is a Microsoft standard
which probably very few people here have
heard of so the history roughly is um
SSL came out in
1994 it was um produced by
Netscape now 1994 those of you here who
are techno history Buffs might recognize
as this was the time of the big browser
Wars or actually this was a little bit
before they started but this was still
um you know the the first Salvo
essentially and Netscape had this nice
secure protocol and we weren't going to
use well we kind of had to for
compatibility but we didn't want to be
bound to Netscape so we came out with
our own protocol called private
communication technology and part of the
excuse for coming out of it was we and
when I say we in this case I I mean
especially Dan Simon who now works in
Windows phone I think um found a big bug
in ssl2 and we said well we can fix that
bug we've got something better and we've
got these nice new features and people
should be using PCT and PCT was put in
browsers and it was default and and it
was even used
occasionally um so the next year
Netscape came out with an improved SSL 3
which fixed the bug and was very common
lots of people use it it's good it's got
some new features well we're still
competing with them we have to come out
with our next version but how how are we
going to even though we put in lots of
enhancements in the new version beat SSL
3 with our new version well the trick is
we come out with version
four and we put out version four which
had some nice
enhancements and four is bigger than
three so it must be
better um and it was enough eventually
to bring Netscape to the table at an
ietf um meeting and we eventually all
got together and agreed on TLS which you
know version one existed for a long time
there is now a slightly newer better
version but but still the it's it's a
very nice protocol it has a lot of good
features and basically the way it works
the thing that has made this survive for
so long is the handshake and the trick
of the handshake is you've got a a a
client and a server and the client
starts off with okay I want to set up a
secure Communication channel here are
the protocols I understand here are the
ciphers I understand here are the tools
here here are the languages I speak in
some sense and the merchant can go
through the list that the U client
provides the server goes through and
says okay I this one's good enough I'll
take that one and the the server gets to
choose okay let's use this protocol
let's use RSA or let's use ECC or let's
use Diffy Helman and let's use this hash
function and this symmetric Cipher I
don't like Dez anymore I'll use AES
whatever but you you can choose and
here's the public key and the
certificate and the nons and then okay
the public key is used to to transmit a
symmetric key and then all the
subsequent communication is with the
symmetric key once you've done this
exchange and the really nice thing about
this is it's very agile we don't have to
decide that next Thursday the internet
is going to change ciphers everybody has
to shut their their old Cipher down and
start using a new Cipher
Thursday it's it's very smooth the
servers hello servers can start
accepting new ciphers browsers clients
can start implementing new ciphers if
they're not yet uh understood by the
servers that's okay um eventually old
ones the servers will stop accepting
it's a smooth gradual process it's very
agile it's very nice it's a good way of
doing this negotiation and this is
allowed the protocol to survive as New
Primitives come along and old ones lose
favor it works quite well okay um once
the negotiation is done you get into the
SSL PCT TLS record layer which basically
says from then on you just use the
symmetric Cipher um that with the with
the key that you just sent over and you
Integrity check it with a hash which
I'll talk more about in another session
and you wind up with what's sometimes
known as hybrid cryptography we use
asymmetric crypto and it's nice
features um for um things that we can't
do like sending a symmetric key to
somebody I've never talked to before um
but the symmetri crypto is much much
much more efficient so once we've done
those things which we can't do without
symm without asymmetric stuff then we do
pretty much everything else
symmetrically and we have this hybrid of
asymmetric wrapping the symmetric keys
or doing the digital signatures and the
bulk stuff is done with a much faster
symmetric
stuff okay so one thing I haven't talked
about much and this is going to be we're
getting close to the end which is good
because I'm getting close to the end of
my slides um is authentication and
ization this is something which has been
done woefully badly in the protocol that
I just showed you and the reason
is when a
merchant
gets um is on the other end of this
conversation gets my credit card number
does the merchant really know who this
Merchant is talking to that that I'm the
one on the other
end no not with basic SSL TLS there is
something called client off that can be
used but it really never is um and all
they have is here's my credit card
number okay I will charge this person I
will assume that you know this credit
card number is good and go from there
but I am my credit card number
effectively that's really not a really
good way of doing things does the
merchant know that I've authorized the
purchase no the merchant just sees my
credit card number coming over the wire
if possession of a credit card number is
used as a proxy for
authentication then I can be
impersonated my claim is this is the
reason for things like the target breach
right people will talk about well Target
had this failing of security this
failing of security no the problem is
right here the problem is target has
data which allows an attacker to to grab
and impersonate millions of people
because all you need to impersonate
somebody is their credit card
number right they have that yeah if we
got rid of that there would be other
sensitive data what purchases I've made
in the last year but people aren't going
to go through too much trouble to steal
that stuff at least not as much trouble
the real problem is we've built this
insane
infrastructure in which credit card
number is everything you have my credit
card number you can impersonate me or
you know other things maybe my credit
card number and my social security
number or my date of
birth I can find for probably most
people in this room find your your date
of birth in in less than two minutes and
your driver's license number which is
all this is all public data very easily
discoverable doesn't cost anything ask
me at the end if you want I'll show you
how to do it um and you it used to be
that um your election records in the
state you could change your address with
your date of birth and driver's license
number turns out the driver's license
number in this state is
deterministically computed from your
date of birth which is
public sorry it that's been fixed a
little bit it's a little bit better now
but not a lot better I I had a
discussion with the director of
Elections a couple years ago and we
agreed um the they've now added driver's
license issue date which is for most
people within 2 months of the expiration
which is on a birthday that's a multiple
of 5 years um so there's about six bits
of entropy in
there better than
nothing okay um also if my giving a
merchant a credit card number is a proxy
for an authorization then Merchants can
cheat all they want they can say well
you told me you wanted to buy this
expensive thing see I you sent me your
credit card number right so you must
have it's not really
authorization so there are ways that we
could do better we could use private
authenticators like what people usually
do with a bank my bank and I somehow
agree on a
password and this password is supposed
to not be shared with anybody else
supposed to be okay that can work
reasonably well for auth iation my bank
can't impersonate me to somebody else if
nobody else recognizes that password as
having any meaning it doesn't have any
authorization value the fact that I gave
my bank a password and gave it some
instructions and it shows this
transcript of all these things that
happened doesn't mean that I was really
on the other end I can say you had my
password to begin with you could have
done that all yourself I how do you know
I was involved in this and of course of
course we all know the usability is
horrible with passwords people can't
remember passwords people are supposed
to have individual passwords with many
many different entities so they wind up
having the same password and it just it
doesn't work
well well Biometrics is a possibility
this has some value for local
authentication it's really bad for
remote authentication and yet people
like to use it for that you see my p my
my fingerprint coming down a wire and
you think I must be on the other end as
though it's some sort of a secret I
leave my fingerprints everywhere I go
it's not a secret it's it's a worse
secret than just about anything else you
can
imagine but somehow seeing my
fingerprint means that I'm there I I I
don't know um so that's really not a
very good choice and of course um
Biometrics are very difficult to revoke
I'd like to keep my fingers thank you
um but you know you have to so treating
Biometrics as some sort of secret data
is is often done and it's a terrible way
to do things it can have value um for a
local
authentication so what we would like to
do um is digital signatures and I think
we've got like two slides left um
digital signatures offer a good
authentication mechanism um you can do
lot with them but you need a public key
infrastructure of some sort to do this
Amazon has gotten a digital certificate
on its key how many people in this room
have a public key that has been
certified by some certifying Authority
uh okay a few but not many until we find
a way of getting there we need the
killer app that'll cause people to get
certified some governments are issuing
cards um to um citizens and if you have
this and a good way of doing this sort
of real authentication um that's great
but until we get there we we're stuck
with Biometrics and passwords and and
broken
systems another thing to mention is
digital
signatures you can't do as a human being
right you need computational
assistance but they they can be used for
authorization if you do it right so I
guess it's a couple more than it's more
than two slides but these are quick
slides sorry so within um SSL PCT TLS
you could imagine you want to make a
purchase you get something that says
please sign this
authorization and you go and say okay
here's here's my signature here's my
certificate there are still problems
with this right it's not quite this
simple you have replay attacks that
signature
could be reused if you don't make sure
that it contains data that won't allow
it so it should have nonces or something
that sort there's also malleability
issues malleability is signatures can be
transformed in various ways or remember
with RSA signing something is exactly
the same as decrypting something so
somebody comes along and says please
sign this authorization when they're
what they're really saying is please
cryp this for
me so we have to build into the
protocols ways of making sure that you
never just sign something that you're
given that the signer also has to put
something into the thing being signed
that's the signer is choosing so it's
not deterministic and there are the
human limitations um of dealing with
um uh just how do you do the computation
people can't digitally sign things
without computational assistance so the
final thing here is we want to get some
sort of hybrid authorization where we
authorize a device our own Computing
device to authorize on our
behalf but how do we do that well that
changes the whole notion normally we
talk about a protocol but instead we
should be talking about what um a former
Microsoft colleague used to like to
refer to as a ceremony it's not just you
and the merchant involved in the
protocol it's you and your device and
your
Merchant and there's an interaction
between you and your device and there's
an interaction between your device and
the merchant whether your device is a
smart card or it's your home PC or your
phone or whatever it is the the protocol
is going all through here and there are
all these places where there could be a
break where this could be a perfect
protocol but the interaction between you
and your device can be taken advantage
of so it should be that when you get to
the point where you tell your device you
want to make a purchase and that gets
passed on there's an authorization step
here there's an authorization step here
and you can enter something that you can
do locally to your device something
reasonably simple and your device then
does the digital authorization but this
all has to be taken into account as a
whole not broken up in P mail
so that's kind of an overview of the the
kinds of things I'll be talking about um
subsequent sessions um whoops um just
went dead there but that's okay uh
subsequent sessions we'll be talking
about um symmetric protocols asymmetric
protocols the sort of standard integer
ones non- integer ones especially
elliptic curves Lattis based systems uh
various protocol properties
um forward secrecy and then some
applications and maybe if if people
allow me I'll sneak in some election
protocols at the very end but if if
people want to hear about other things
uh if people are less interested in some
of these things there are other things
let me know uh I want to keep this
flexible and and um try to find a way to
sort of fit what it what things people
want to hit on okay oh and by the way
all the other sessions 1927 I apolog for
the room confusion I think that must
have been my uh my office is building
112 my admin's office is building 112
somehow that slipped in so we are in 99
but the future sessions will be in 1927
it's a smaller room that way just around
the corner okay so that's it any
questions
Denny um so you showed RSA yep vanilla
version of RSA uhuh you talk about
centic security at
all yeah yeah I um you know maybe not in
exactly that form but but yeah the the
RSA that I showed nobody in their right
Minds would use that in practice you you
you um have to be very careful about
exactly how you pad things um in in the
actual use of RSA and I'll I'll talk
about that to among other things make
sure that encryption is distinct from
signatures um and there there is no
possibility of confusion but there are
um a lot of things the semantic security
that you mentioned um is is one
important aspect of um understanding you
exactly the kind of security that that
RSA can provide yeah I do hope to to
talk about that as
well yep uh that last example of the
ceremony device during the authorization
is Chip and pin credit cards an example
of yeah chip chip and pin does that it
doesn't solve all the problems because
chip and pin typically the way it's used
credit card numbers still get
transferred um and and maintain so it's
better but chip and pin which is done a
lot in Europe and there's now some
expectation that they'll come in the US
for people who don't know it basically
it's not enough to swipe a credit card
you have to have a pin also so okay the
there is a pin on the credit card and
the credit card is supposed to engage in
a more sophisticated protocol than the
usual one of here I am here's my number
anybody want my number um which is what
um you know many of our cards do like
you know our orer cards basically you
ping them and you know here's my
information um we we want to do better
than that we can do better than that
chip and pin is a little bit better than
what we're doing but it's not what we
should be doing yeah you had one talk
about the symmetric uh algorithms as Des
yep yep you talking about modes okay the
cyer modes yes yes I I actually debated
whether or not to put in Cipher modes
today and I decided you know we're
already overtime so I'm glad I didn't
but we'll we'll spend plenty of time
talking about Cipher modes schedule to
go till 3 um the usual way this is done
um is you know an hour talk plenty of
time for questions will will be flexible
so um that if if people would like hour
and a half talks I I can talk at nausea
my promise but um the tradition anyway
is it's it's on the calendar till 3
o'clock so that there's some flexibility
at the end um so um I'm not g to talk
about Cipher modes now I'll talk about
them next time unless you really want
something talk to me later I'm curious
uh there's a lot of government
databases that whole very very sensitive
information regarding individuals for um
medical
purposes how good are those um question
okay you know sorry uh what's the
quality of medical databases and and
other similar databases it's very mixed
you know some are pretty good some
are not nearly as good as they should be
but
um there are problems in just sort of
what's in there um usually there's a lot
more in there that needs to be that
should be medical databases are kind of
an exception because that's you know
very sensitive stuff that really does
need to be there for the most part um so
that's a case where we have to try to be
very careful and instead you know not
expose them as much as they tend to be
exposed they they need some extra
security as opposed to Target which
probably doesn't need the extra security
if what they store is only what you
bought in the last two years it's still
kind of sensitive but it's a lot less
sensitive than what medical tests I've
had in the last two
years I don't there isn't a good answer
to that it's it's not great um and we
can talk about some some methods that
are used but um
it's you you probably don't want to know
all the
details actually I do okay we can we can
talk a little bit and and honestly I
don't know all the details I know some
of it but but but not all of it yeah go
back to next night about the
exponentiation where you multiplied
multiple times to go to n okay you know
what I'm going to try to do it this
one well Josh P up that uh slide if if
anybody who's here has not signed the
spreadsheet on your way out the door and
please do on the back table now oh no I
ah
H the wrong I hit F5 instead of shift
F5 uh this
one yeah
okay uh you want to go a little further
very close simp so let's do exponential
yes this one yep so if someone knows how
many times did you exponentiated and how
many times did you added is it hard to
reach to n or is it computationally um
if it's just the number of times then
you're pretty secure because there
aren't that many possibilities the
number of times that you've well this is
square and multiply here um you're
always doing the same number of squares
or basically you should always be doing
the number number of squares the
multiplies the number of multiplies that
you do should be clustered tightly
around half of the number of squares and
if knowing that allowed you to actually
figure out somebody's key there aren't
that many possibilities you could guess
that and and try it the problem though
is that sometimes if you're close in you
can actually you know tell the
difference the the usual approach is not
um do all the squares and then do a
bunch of multiplies it's while you're
doing it you square and then multiply or
Square and then not
multiply and if you're not careful in
your implementation then there's a side
Channel attack and probably I should put
on the list side Channel attacks which
has been some time talking about some
some of those um but there's a side
Channel attack which is just sort of a
timing attack or power analysis or
listening to if you can get close enough
to a device uh can even be done
acoustically listening to it um you can
um record it and listen and and tell the
difference between a a multiply and a
not multiply and that way you get the
bits of the key one at a time and that
would be very detrimental so we are very
careful in our implementations one of
the reasons you should use the Microsoft
internal approved implementations and
not roll your own is we're very aware of
side Channel attacks and try to build as
much resistance as we
can anything else okay confused about
one point if you go back about two
slides to the SL that had the 2048 on it
okay um what uh yep so this one I
thought that you said the crypto board
recommends that all three be 20 48 ad
one of those everybody uses 65537 and so
can you explain right uh these two need
to be um 20 48 bit the uh oh sorry not
these these two uh the was X that was
65537 it's it's it's n that's important
here why is the message so y will be
padded separately um it's the it's just
the message the message means that the
computations will be done on 20 48 bit
values it's just how many computations
and it turns out that with RSA as long
as you're you're a little careful about
it a small exponent seems to be just as
good as a large exponent you get some
interesting effects out of this um and
it's worth mentioning this exponent is
going to be public anyway so you're not
hiding anything
by um or or revealing anything by using
a special form the question is does it
make it easier to attack it turns out
that if you want something that's of
this special form one all zeros and a
one there there are very few
possibilities that meet all the
requirements um three actually does but
there is some reason not to use three
there are some attacks on very very
small exponents if they're used
carelessly basically you could get
something that doesn't get large enough
to wrap mod in um and if you pad very
badly and you just use raw RSA you don't
wrap mod in then it just becomes taking
cube roots um so we want something
that's
small has this structure and sort of
65537 has turned out to be like the
perfect value and virtually everybody
uses it um it leads to this interesting
asymmetry in asymmetric encryption with
RSA in that encryption is much much
faster than decryption a couple of
orders of magnitude faster verifying a
signature is much faster than signing
something because the verification is
with the small exponent the um
decryption and root um which is root
finding um
is um it's also just an exponentiation
it just turns out to be a large
exponentiation you use a full size so in
that case the exponent becomes 20 48
bits here um so you wind
up encryption and decryption are using
basically the same function but the
exponent is much larger for the secret
operation
and therefore encryption is fast
decryption is slow um often you can use
that to your
benefit sometimes you wind up on the
wrong side of it you wind up with a weak
client having to do the expensive
operation and that that's a nuisance and
we we try to formulate things when we
can so that it's the other way around
but we can't always do
that yeah go into this a lot more detail
in your third talk uh yeah I think it's
third talk is when it's it's most likely
yep yes and I do intend to show you
actually how we compute these
things yeah if you like math that's the
talk to come
to okay anything
else okay well thank you again be sure
you sign the sheet if you wanted chance
with the
trinket